the neurology of reading is another
thing that people are writing about and
investigating a lot that is what happens
in your brain when you rage it turns out
because I know a friend who had this
kind of stroke you can have a kind of
stroke that makes it possible for you to
write you can still write but you can't
read what you've just written so reading
and writing you would think would be in
the same little little box in the brain
but but they're not anything that we do
is built on a pre-existing brain
platform or program which is then
adopted for other uses so language is
pretty old and it's also built in some
children arrive in the world and then
they pick up language just by being
around other people who are talking
nobody sits down and teaches them
reading on the other hand you will not
pick up unless somebody will spend some
time with you and writing is even
writing by hand as apparently even even
harder so what are the platforms that
that these things are built on and it
has been proposed that reading is built
on a very ancient program that had to do
with with reading animal tracks
so what you're doing is you're looking
at visual signs made by somebody else
and you are interpreting those back into
a story that originally of course
allowed you to track the animal or to
figure out if an animal was tracking you
equally important
you were able to tell what was around in
your vicinity by reading those tracks so
what are those marks we make what are
those marks on a sheet of paper piece of
stone clay tablet they're like animal
tracks and that we look at them we and
we translate them back into something
which which
language and that language can be put
together in our brains to tell a story
create a poem
whatever the writing may have been as
for the writing those are the tracks we
make so that's probably based on some
sort of display or marking program and
that too is pretty old if you go back to
cave painting so the handprints on the
cave drawings on the cave the markings
the pieces of stone or bone that they've
now found with rhythmic scratches on
them they're they're all forms of
signaling so it took a while for that to
to become what we now know as as
alphabets or language systems but it
probably all had its origins in that
form of marking and somebody has a
theory that all of the alphabets are
taken from from natural that they had
their origins and natural signs from
pictographs of depicting natural things